we start off though with chief White
House correspondent John Roberts to tell
us where things stand right now good
evening John
I get any bread you can see Chad program
right in the thick of things there on
Capitol Hill as the conferees tried to
hash out a deal by Friday President
Trump is keeping up the political
pressure on them to give him border
security and a wall the president will
be in El Paso Texas tonight for a big
campaign style rally and earlier today
at the White House an afternoon meeting
with law enforcement officers in a pre
departure meeting with local sheriff's
six from border states president Trump
today rip the Democrats for wanting to
cut the number of spaces ice has to
detain illegal immigrants many of them
criminals not only don't they want to
give us the money for the wall they
don't want to give us the space to
detain murderers criminals drug dealers
human smugglers the president is
outraged that Democratic conferees are
insisting on cutting the number of ice
beds to detain people already in the
country illegally 216 thousand two
hundred and fifty the Democrats want to
cut what they take out ms-13 and others
by the thousands and they want to cut
ice so we're not gonna let that happen
president Trump read new statistics from
last year that show illegal immigrants
were convicted of sixteen hundred and
forty one homicides nearly 1300
kidnappings almost four thousand sexual
assaults and nearly 30 thousand assaults
among other crimes the president insists
cutting the number of ice beds would
force the government to release
criminals into society sheriffs at the
White House today said that would be a
bad idea what happens at the border who
doesn't stay at the poor
they come to our communities in Ohio in
Maryland in North Carolina in Georgia oh
how you talk across this country but
Democrats say it would force the
administration to focus on detaining and
deporting criminals and not people who
are simply in the country illegally
we're talking about beds sufficient not
to deal with criminals which is what the
case is now but dealing with people who
are working paying taxes in our
community as the president heads to a
political rally in El Paso a war of
words with El Paso's mayor who took
issue with the president's State of the
Union claim last week considered one of
our nation's most dangerous cities now
immediately upon its building with a
powerful barrier in place El Paso is one
of the safest cities mayor de Margo
crediting El Paso safety it's a law
enforcement not a border wall it's part
of the process for border security but
it's not the total panacea the president
Trump found himself at odds with leaders
in another state California's governor
Gavin Newsom saying today that he is
going to pull back the bulk of his
National Guard troops from the border
saying he is not going to allow them to
participate in what he called political
theater and just before he left the
White House this afternoon President
Trump was asked if there would be
another shutdown his answer that's up to
the Democrats Brett
John Roberts Lava the North Lawn John
thanks